we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p today's voicemail is a
very practical question about the
Democratic primary I David so now that
Bernie Sanders just won the first couple
of primaries and caucuses and he's
polling well going into Super Tuesday
mathematically speaking what's the
fastest way he could wrap this up and
what's the earliest we could know who
the nominee is going to be presuming
that it will be Bernie
which hopefully it will be so listen uh
I don't
if the Brits know to word this if the
nominee is going to be Bernie we are not
going to know that very soon the things
that we could know soon are and I really
think we'll know by Super Tuesday does
anybody really have a path to half of
the delegates before the convention or
is it going to be a brokered contested
or maybe a better term as negotiated
convention contested implies something
different but will it be a negotiated
convention we will probably know that by
midnight on Tuesday
if Bernie is going to get half of the
delegates from primaries from winning
primaries I think we're not going to
know for a while particularly once
Michael Bloomberg wins some delegates on
Tuesday it will become even more split
so it's going to be a while it's gonna
be a while we've got a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about the
death of Hosni Mubarak the Egyptians
strong man who was undone by the Arab
Spring we will also talk about the u.s.
losing the toilet race it's a weird
story but a relevant one and we will
also talk about how there has been a
spike in the number of seniors using
cannabis edibles and also smoking pot
what is behind it what does it mean all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show grab a membership or become a
patron to get instant access otherwise
as sad as it is we will speak to you
next tomorrow